suddenly I found myself tossed into this  dark place like it's so scared I don't  know what it's the same before Italy I  had a happy life it was very important  for me to get out of my comfort zone and  see if that made me turn into an adult  when I was with Amanda it was so happy  what happened that night Amanda knocks  some of the information that came out  was just completely made-up it made  headlines all over the world trial of  the decade it was crazy the whole world  knew who I had ever had sex with she was  terrified  I felt like a child again and I knew  like I was a kid  you  that's everyone's nightmare either I'm a  psychopath in sheep's clothing or I am  you